5 26 on your Monday morning here's
something that's not driving you crazy
it is the power of speaking of
when the new bridge connecting does it
in from the area east of Nellis all the
way to Hollywood opened early this year
everyone thought it was great until the
people who live south of di off of theme
Road realized the constant flow of cars
east and west on di made it hard to get
on in virtually impossible during rush
hour got a lot of viewer emails
complaining that the situation was made
even worse by construction on nearby
Vegas Valley which flooded di with even
more cars well on Friday the county put
out a news release on the all way stop
signs that have been put in to give
those theme Road drivers easier access
to Di
but when I was out there yesterday there
were a few I'm in a hurry club members
ignoring the DI stop sign but I have to
guess the number of crashes the high
blood pressure situations is down from
before the stop sign installations
County Commissioner for the area Tech
second Bloom thanking the County's
Public Works Department for responding
quickly to the complaint buckle up drive
carefully and please put down that phone
you can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com